first they compared parents to domestic
terrorists now we're learning of another
teachers union doing the dirty work for
democrats fox news has learned that just
after the national school boards
association sent that infamous letter to
the white house in which it compared
parents to domestic terrorists america's
largest educators union sent a very
similar letter to social media giants
urging them to quote stifle propaganda
about critical race theory and described
parents in these terms quote the
alarming growth of a small but violent
group of radicalized adults who falsely
believe that graduate level courses
about racism are being taught in k-12
public schools because of misinformation
spread on social media jesse parents
will not be silenced and this teacher's
union is awfully dumb for a bunch of
educators to think that they can do that
they're whining to the refs like losers
do i mean they're like they're like oh
facebook time out that was a foul
someone posted something mean on
facebook kick him out
it's like the same people you see at the
club tapping the bouncer on the shoulder
hey
hey uh the table over here has been a
little too loud and they spilled a drink
on my loafer and it's gucci get them out
of here like first they complain to big
government then they complained to big
tech
this is a rambunctious country degen
these are passionate people we have
freedom of speech freedom of assembly
this is how this country's always been
because we care about life
and you can't just all of a sudden start
teaching kindergarteners racism
and then when the parents pick it and
post something you can't run and hide
and say they're trying to kill me lock
them up censor them it's not how things
work these people need to get together
stop acting like children act like
adults talk to each other learn from
each other and just finish the school
year like normal people
but brian they also have to worry this
has gone further with merrick garland
essentially sickened because of that
national school boards association memo
which again we found out that the
secretary of education cardona requested
the original letter it's this this
circle
of
targeting parents again merrick garland
the fbi and the doj going after parents
and just what in the last few days the
justice department announced it's
forming a new domestic terrorism unit
who do you think they're going after
mama and papa well i really
yeah i really believe that the whole
virginia situation uh didn't get out of
hand because the media uh we would not
let it go because we just exposed it we
showed the video and say this has got to
stop what exactly are they saying but my
advice to the parents is don't make it
easy don't lose your temper write some
points down you probably have good solid
points you're certainly passionate ian
pryor is a great example of it he's a
teacher excuse me he's a parent that saw
the teachers
were off the reservation so he organized
the parents to fight back and that
started this whole movement it was
organic it was real and i would just say
this get the kids back in school is the
overarching thing it looks like kids are
organizing they're making their own
demands that's the new trend and in new
york city mr mayor do not cave to the
unions cases are down from ninety
thousand to thirty thousand keep the
kids in school even if it's ten kids do
not break and go back to the virtual
schooling harold
i don't disagree much i do i did take a
note that jesse must have had a bouncer
tap because he spilled something on
somebody when he was in a bar one time
but
why short of that i do think we
we ought to be more focused on teaching
critical english critical math critical
science in our schools i i've said it
many times if you want to if you want to
show a politician that he or she is
wrong unelect them don't don't impose
violence or threaten them with violence
i think that is a line it should not be
crossed but big tech is going to have to
kind of have to balance this one out and
measure how they get involved because uh
parents certainly that shouldn't be in
big tech
sorry i didn't mean to cut you but a
line that shouldn't be crossed as well
is these big tech companies shouldn't be
willing to silence these parents and
believe me the teachers unions are doing
this because they believe they have a
sympathetic year and the big tech
companies have shown a willingness to
silence these parents speaking up you
mentioned ian pryor he said quote this
looks like a concerted effort between
the federal government and these outside
groups like the nea and the nsba to
interfere with the first amendment
rights of parents uh he's he's he's
fighting the fight and he's telling
parents to stand up
the parents know though they don't need
facebook and they don't need twitter or
tick tock they
they
do old school signs and go and stand out
in front of their kids school and the
cameras show up and that's how the
american people realize and parents
everywhere from coast to coast realize
they're all in it together and they're
and these unions are all trying to get
one over on them backed by the democrats
which jesse's talked about hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else